أعتقد أننا لم نعلنها
خطر مع هذا هو أننا ذاهبون إلى
رفع شخصية
التمثيل الرسمي في فلسطين
القائم بالأعمال الذي سنذهب إليه اليوم
لفتح سفارة أثناء عملنا
حكومة
التمثيل الذي يتوافق و
طلب الطلب في جميع الأماكن شيء
شيء أساسي جدًا بسيط جدًا
لكن هذا اليوم يجعلنا
هو أن الحق محترم
دولي
ولا شيء أكثر ولا أقل من ذلك
أن هذا الاقتناع العميق يعرف ذلك
هنا لديهم صديق في الاحترام
الكثير من تقاليدها أن هذا في لا
في حالة إساءة فهم هذا ، فلنقم بذلك و
دعونا نفكر في هذه التصرفات من الحب في
أفكر في حالتي من
الاعتراف بكرامة
الشعوب هذا هو ما يتوافق
[موسيقى]
هم دول وشعوب شقيقة نتمنى
أتمنى أن يستمر هذا النجم في إلقاء الضوء على بلدنا
طريق السلام والعدالة نحو
الحرية والعودة إلى
العدالة الاجتماعية ومكافأة أكثر إنصافًا